debate club Theo does JP come to you
from Augusta Georgia home of the Gustav
green jackets my league baseball team
and I'm come to you with a debate club
who should feel date next Carly or
Hannah that Alabama kept fish noodle er
hitter or that Los Angeles Korean
barbecue eating dinner or that that the
cream bar oh you big tip he got help
married it you know big tick carly was
feeling you I think that that little
[ __ ] southern belle with the knuckle
deep and the catfish is the way to go
do you think he's out there yes she
seemed real nice she is bad yeah bad to
the bone that's beautiful fish to my
thing that hates or is a catfish that's
true huh hmm and she have serve up
catfish too
every night catfish mm-hmm yeah you know
this past weekend you got no fish yeah
you catch all the fish boy yeah I love
that grouper right done it's [ __ ] Oh
beat me in the face with that dirty
grouper that's what you like dang Carl
Wow 54% for hot Carl I disagree wow it's
a neck-and-neck over there though oh I
can't believe they didn't go with fish
woman how do you call fish woman what do
you think Kat I think Hannah is more of
your girl now that fish hannah with that
with that southern twang that she's
bodied up and has a [ __ ] together
I know if you'd notice she's driving a
$70,000 Raptor drunk yeah Wow you might
time I mean my Paul Wow damn she's a
first team all badi I thought you said
she was driving a rav4 did you tell me
that nah they'd been sad
oh yeah that one that helped her case
done and I'm hot now hot Karl tits here
no [ __ ] slouch either and here's Chen
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh Hanna has a man Oh [ __ ] was
that you lying [ __ ] no yeah we got
[ __ ] catfish dude nope that's her man
maybe she just took him out for a nice
hunt does anybody want to guess the
weight of my blue cap before I post a
video hint it's not as big as my
whatever whatever to safing about the
dude know that that dude has a better
body than both of us how about me dawg
oh definitely might have better biceps
and maybe I don't think it's better
nipples you have a better ass definitely
you have better set of tits out the back
is that a different dude no same guy
with her again because I thought there's
a real connection oh you know it's kind
of sure oh brother but I'll tell you
this okay what you can freak about my
boy Ryan shotgun Raptor he looks a
little bit like you affiliate kind of
microwave and it could be cousins for
sure dude you know what he knows his way
around a catfish she's gonna connect
that's true man well look I run a
catfish I do I could catch a catfish and
show that lady what's up but I can't
catch him what you know I'm not doing it
maybe we should ask her hot corals out
there drinking that close to our open
stove yeah Carl take advantage a
situation and [ __ ] drank seven
[ __ ] what were you sipping on soju
soju
well that was chin who got her drunk and
then left and then one eye in the
[ __ ] tits man the whole time I stare
at our kids that makes more than I'm
married sounded like a little Mickey
everything
the mic hot Karl man if it Dafoe percent
phone we'll see and you can't go wrong
with either but I don't know how Karl
does for a job Han either [ __ ] had her
[ __ ] together dude I don't know for
reaching in new large animals mouths bro
has really have no [ __ ] she does what
she loves that's a good point but does
she make a living doing I guess you just
sell the fish time Wow
yeah never mind that man I guess we'll
see man I say go on a date with each of
them let us film it and see how it goes
we'll see what Hannah you mean the
backyard [ __ ] sticks in that Raptor
mud slinging oatmeal slurping slapping
yeah fish on the riddle she cooks a lot
she has like videos deep down that
profile it was she's the baddest cat
Fisher catcher in the world that's true
look I think that right there wood is
really the tiebreaker for me
oh you should see if he can catfish sure
there's gonna be something on the grill
when I get home you know yeah and I
don't have to catch it you have to do
anything nice and easy oh well after
about three weeks of eating catfish
every night gets a little old seems like
that's all she know but you get half
catfish nuggets man catfish popsicles
mmm
what's what's hot Karl gonna bring to
the table though she took advantage our
friend chin here and drank all that
[ __ ] sake and barbecue and then it
was down to going after party
yeah and chin left her for his damn
white mother well maybe that's what you
should do with Hannah go out with her
and then come out with wife oh wow Dan
pull the old catfish on her get that big
put a yeah but just what if I just
showed up with my hand down her throat I
think you have to ask for consent first
okay
well you never know if I'll put a ring
in it she might true you never know man
she lives in Alabama though I live here
she's a huge boyfriend these are all
great point
we can who has the word gun I think it
is uh I G name these are great points
Hanna's are Carly's local and single so
yeah and the flick she did make a pass
at you maybe she was like I pretty sure
she's like video single holla
she's like Theo holla we'll see man
we'll see what's up right now I'm just
trying to take it easy local traffic
right now you can get here from like
yeah but that but I hit traffic coming
in that traffic's picking up I'm with
deal he wants to slurp local we are
moving podcast to Houston closer closer
a property closer not Houston Austin ah
but look man whatever happens dude I'm
down for something we'll see what
happens man we'll see we're local
I'm gonna pray about it there you go
i'ma pray about it
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]